>>> COVID CONCERNS IN SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
NOW LEADING TO DANGEROUS
SITUATIONS FOR SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBERS.
THEY'RE WORRIED FOR THEIR OWN
SAFETY.
AFTER AN INCREASING NUMBER OF
THREATS LIKE THESE.
>> CALM DOWN.
CALM DOWN.
WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> WE KNOW WHO YOU ARE.
>> I'M GOING TO COME FOR
EVERYBODY THAT COMES AT MY KID
WOULD THIS STUPID, RIDICULOUS
MANDATE!
>> WE ARE THE STORM.
AND WE ARE HERE ALREADY.
AND WHEN THIS WHOLE THING
CRUMBLES TO THE GROUND, WE WILL
BE HERE TO HOLD YOU ACCOUNTABLE
FOR YOUR CRIMES AGAINST
HUMANITY.
>> NO MORE MASKS!
NO MORE MASKS!
>> LOOK.
LOOK, RIGHT HERE.
AS YOU CAN SEE, FISTS ARE NOW
FLYING.
ALL OF THIS ON LIVE TELEVISION.
FISTS ARE FLYING.
.
>> YOU ARE ALLOWING CHILD ABUSE.
YOU ARE ALLOWING CHILD ABUSE.
YOU WITH YOUR NOTTY LITTLE FACE,
YOU'RE ALLOWING IT AS WELL.
>> THE NATIONAL SCHOOL BOARD
ASSOCIATION IS ASKING THE WHITE
HOUSE AND THE EDUCATION
DEPARTMENT TO HELP ENSURE THE
SECURITY OF ITS MEMBERS.
AND THE GROUP'S PRESIDENT VIOLA
GARCIA IS JOINING US TO TALK
ABOUT ALL ON OF THIS.
THANKS FOR BEING WITH US THIS
MORNING.
YOU SENT A LETTER TO PRESIDENT
BIDEN BECAUSE YOU SAY YOU ARE
UNDER IMMEDIATE THREAT, FOR
FEDERAL ENFORCEMENT AND OTHER
ASSISTANCE TO DEAL WITH SOME OF
WHAT WE JUST SAW.
TELL US WHAT EXACTLY YOU THINK
YOUR MEMBERS NEED.
>> WELL, WE NEED SUPPORT.
WE NEED REINFORCEMENT OF THE
SUPPORT THAT THE COMMUNITY CAN
GIVE US.
BUT PORE IMPORTANTLY, THESE ARE
REAL THREATS, BRIANNA, THAT YOU
JUST SAW -- THAT WE ALL JUST
SAW.
AND THEY'RE OCCURRING WITH
GREATER FREQUENCY.
SO OUR LETTER TO THE WHITE HOUSE
REALLY IS INDICATIVE OF THE
SERIOUSNESS OF THE SITUATION FOR
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
BUT MORE ESPECIALLY FOR STUDENTS
IN OUR PUBLIC SCHOOLS.
>> TELL US MORE ABOUT THESE
THREATS.
WHAT SCHOOL BOARDS AND MEMBERS
ARE EXPERIENCING.
.
>> WELL, YOU HAVE SEEN ON THE
VIDEOS HERE THAT WE AS SCHOOL
BOARD MEMBERS HAVE BEEN IN
COMMUNICATION WITH OUR
COMMUNITIES FOR
AIM TO LISTEN TO THE COMMUNITY,
WE'RE RESPECTFUL OF THE
OPINIONS, WE UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE ARE VARIOUS OPINIONS ON
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS HAVE BEEN
WORKING DURING THE PANDEMIC,
DURING THIS HEIGHTENED POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING FOR A YEAR
AND A HALF DURING THE PANDEMIC.
WE HAVE SAFELY GOTTEN STUDENTS
BACK IN SCHOOL.
WE KNOW THOSE ARE THE MOST
IMPORTANT THINGS THAT SCHOOLS
NEED TO BE DOING NOW.
AND SO SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE
PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY.
THEY GO TO THE GROCERY STORES,
THEY SHOP WITH THE NEIGHBORS
THAT ARE AROUND THEM.
AND --
>> ARE THEY BEING THREATENED,
YOU KNOW, WHEN THEY'RE GROCERY
SHOPPING?
DO THEY HAVE PEOPLE COMING TO
THEIR HOUSES?
ARE THERE THREATS AGAINST THEIR
CHILDREN?
>> THE GREATEST INCIDENTS OF
THREATS WE HAVE SEEN ARE THE
ONES THAT YOU DEMONSTRATED, THE
ONES VIA INTERNET CONNECTIONS,
ACROSS STATE LINES.
WE HAVE SEEN THAT THE -- MANY OF
THE MESSAGES ARE VERY SIMILAR.
SO WE RARELY, I DON'T KNOW THE
NUMBER OF INCIDENTS PERHAPS IN
GROCERY STORES, BUT THE GREATEST
NUMBER AND THE BIGGEST CONCERN
WE HAVE ARE THE THREATS OF
VIOLENCE, THE COORDINATED
EFFORTS THAT WE SEEM TO SEE
BECAUSE OF THE SIMILARITIES
ACROSS THE STATE LINES, AND SO
IT GIVES US PAUSE, GREAT PAUSE
BECAUSE NOT ONLY ARE WE CHARGED
AT SCHOOL -- AT SCHOOL BOARD
LEVEL, FOR THE ACADEMIC
VIABILITY OF OUR STUDENTS, BUT
WE ALSO ARE CHARGED WITH THE
SAFETY AND SECURITY NOT ONLY OF
THE STUDENTS, BUT OF THE STAFF,
AND THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS THAT
COME IN AND OUT OF OUR
BUILDINGS.
AND SO THIS IS A CONCERN.
>> WELL, VIOLA, THOSE VIDEOS WE
SEE ARE INCREDIBLY SCARY.
WE KNOW THIS IS INCREASING AND
WE'LL KEEP AN